bueno
en el imaginario de la cultura popular
el artista suele ser un personaje un
poco mitificado tal vez hay una cuestión
de cliché ahí gracias también a lo que
ocurre en las series de televisión
películas
aparece a veces un personaje que suele
ser un poco extraño que habla de cosas
extrañas
y en ocasiones puede ser así porque
solemos ser agentes un poco subversivos
y diferentes a los contextos de otras
personas en sus ámbitos
pero bueno para como yo sé que a veces
podemos ser un poco molestos o canciones
voy a pararme desde otro ámbito uno que
a mí me gusta mucho y el cual es la
cultura popular precisamente es un
terreno que como un acuerdo para todos
todos sabemos hoy en día lo que está
pasando
y para esto quiero mostrarles los iconos
actuales de la cultura popular
entonces pues bueno ellos no necesitan
presentación creo que todos los
conocemos batman y iron man y bueno
además de lo evidente que tienen en
común ellos
y uno de los elementos más importantes a
mi juicio es la vulnerabilidad el hecho
de que a diferencia de otros héroes
ellos tienen
una parte humana muy desarrollada porque
eso es lo que esos son humanos no tienen
superpoderes o grandes habilidades sino
actúan desde desde sus defectos tienen
problemas personales tienen problemas
morales y estas son las cosas que más
los enriquecen pero bueno seguramente
todo esto ustedes ya lo conocían hasta
el momento no les he dicho nada nuevo
quiero contarles la historia de otro
personaje
no tan famoso pero creo que es
igualmente valiosa no tan adornada pero
creo que es muy pertinente para esta
situación
nuestro personaje un día estuvo con sus
padres en una feria aquí muy conocida el
ego con fest una feria para niños y
estando en esta feria es división los
niños a lo lejos trató de acercarse de
ellos pero los niños que así que de
inmediato lo rechazaron
tal vez él pensó que había alguna razón
de fondo para esto
pero entonces no le prestaron atención
tal vez por lo que eran mayores no
sabemos de todas formas el regreso con
sus padres su padre abrió una maleta que
traía saco un elemento y le dijo toma
colócate tu armadura y ve de nuevo con
ellos a ver qué pasa acto seguido él fue
con los niños y de inmediato cambió la
actitud de ellos se transformaron vieron
en una persona nueva y se maravillaron
por cómo era ahora por cómo se veía
después de que estaban en la feria
deambulando varios de los niños los
señalaban 67 niños que los rodearon en
esa ocasión lo señalaban y decían mira
mamá ese es mi amigo que tiene un brazo
de iron man o mira mamá
ese es mi amigo el que es como ironman
dar con el nombre de
se llama jose gabriel
bueno posteriormente lo tengo no traído
positiva sin embargo
jose gabriel es un niño el cual presenta
una condición muy particular él carece
de uno de sus brazos y es una realidad
para muchos niños acá en colombia en
latinoamérica
son niños los cuales están en
condiciones de vulnerabilidad por
factores socioeconómicos por factores de
diferentes situaciones
algunos sometidos a problemas de
bullying y esto digamos no les permite
tener un desarrollo como es debido
normalmente los papás son los que sufren
mucho más por ellos
nosotros hemos desarrollado una técnica
o una manera de atacar digamos esta
problemática en nuestra corporación lo
que nos dedicamos a hacer es un trabajo
de hacer prótesis con impresión 3d y las
damos gracias a algunos patrocinadores
algunas personas que nos ayudan en esta
labor gracias a empresas privadas o
personas naturales
claro está
algunos de estos niños
ha sufrido de ciertas condiciones y
cierto rechazo he escuchado algunas
anécdotas acerca de
como los tratan sus compañeros muchas
veces los adultos hacen partícipe de
estos mismos juicios he escuchado
anécdotas de niños como por ejemplo
carlitos un niño que vive en cimitarra
santander una vereda lejana en la cual
la gente por culpa de la
desescolarización o la ignorancia tal
vez ha sufrido una transformación
negativa a carlitos muchas veces le
hacían acusaciones como él está maldito
él es hijo del [ __ ] cosas así solo
porque le faltaba uno de sus brazos y la
gente puede ser muy dura y muy severa
con este tipo de acusaciones
niños que a veces tienen la tendencia a
jugar con sus juguetes a quitarles los
brazos y colocarse los ellos una
anécdota de esto también es un niño que
hacía esto y su maestra le preguntaba
por qué hacía esto
él le dijo es que un monstruo se comió
mi brazo
y cada niño tiene una curiosidad
diferente
él es jose gabriel en la actualidad que
está en su última entrega de prótesis y
pues ya ha aprendido a manejarla con una
motricidad más fina
como se podrá notar también
he podido observar muchas veces lo que
proponemos nosotros es es una forma para
que ellos se superen a sí mismos
esta herramienta de a veces de la
personalización a través del fuego a
través de aditamentos a través de
utensilios que les hagan sentirse como
como su héroe su personaje favorito
ha sido algo muy valioso para el proceso
de ellos porque toca su autoestima toca
su propia identidad
pero bueno ya de por si muchos de ellos
tienen grandes capacidades
he visto niños que sin sus dos brazos
pueden armar un cubo de rubik completo
niños que sin sus piernas con elementos
protésicos pueden jugar fútbol
que pueden jugar más que yo aunque yo no
juego nada mi familia desde futbolistas
pero bueno yo tengo físico de
ajedrecista
el caso de ángel gabriel un niño que
visitamos hace poco en perú y él también
tiene una gran particularidad es un niño
que a pesar de su condición que él
carece de sus cuatro extremidades no le
tiene miedo na no le tiene pena a nada
él puede hablar con extranjeros sin
ningún problema y vive en una zona
apartada de la ciudad
él no tiene pena hablar en internet
hablar en medios a dar entrevistas habla
muy fácil con cualquier persona y a
partir de su propia condición él motiva
a todos los que pueden porque le
entiende muy bien su situación
y claro esta llega el caso también de
algunos niños que a través de su entidad
prestadora de salud pueden obtener
algunos de estos dispositivos hay una
gran cantidad hay una inmensa mayoría de
niños que de pronto no puede acceder a
ellos por sus propias condiciones pero
para los que si pueden
llegan a obtener un dispositivo como
este tipo
una prótesis de gancho o una pinzas de
cangrejo cosas que de pronto uno no le
cabe en la cabeza cómo es que pueden ser
claro esta parte desde una perspectiva
muy funcional y no les voy a decir
mentiras estas prótesis son muy
funcionales pero tal vez están pensadas
en cierta medida para los adultos
a veces un auto se puede sentir incómodo
pero tal vez no es algo tan problemático
pero para un niño que está entrando a su
etapa escolar tal vez de 86 años
es algo un poco crítico no los mismos
padres sufren al ver a su hijo con este
tipo de elementos y es una forma también
de victimizar los llama mucho la
atención pero de una forma negativa
cuando podríamos hacer que llamen la
atención de una manera positiva
muchos papás sienten terror al ver esto
al lado de uno de sus hijos porque
parece un objeto contundente
y bueno por supuesto también estamos
hemos trabajado el caso de adultos ellos
buscan otro tipo de inclusión realmente
es una inclusión un poco más funcional
en el ámbito de que ellos quieren ser
útiles otra vez a la sociedad quieren
reintegrarse tal vez no quiere llamar la
atención sino quieren volver a trabajar
quieren volver a ser personas de un acto
actores de lo cotidiano
y pues acá tenemos un par de ejemplos de
personas con las que hemos trabajado
pero claro esto conlleva una gran
responsabilidad no solo el hecho de la
personalización que a veces proponemos
sino también el hecho de la parte física
y funcional
nosotros tenemos hoy en día un equipo
también con el que contamos
que se ha nutrido del conocimiento de
muchas personas
contamos con desde mi profesión desde
las artes plásticas tal vez un enfoque
un poco diferente
pero este proyecto ha nacido desde la
ingeniería mecatrónica ingeniería
biomecánica tenemos ingeniería biomédica
claro tenemos psicología fisioterapia
terapia ocupacional tenemos asistencia
técnica en el desarrollo de elementos
artísticos y protésicos desde un ámbito
clásico porque obviamente tampoco lo
podemos dejar atrás
esto es pues nuestro nuestro nuestro
equipo actual bueno hay dos integrantes
que no llegaron a tiempo para la foto
uno está en alemania haciendo su
doctorado del otro estaba casándose por
esos días
pero igual llegaron a tiempo y pues de
pronto los envidiosos dirán que sus
fotos
entonces
muchas veces la tecnología y la
innovación son herramientas que van de
la mano y para nosotros en la impresión
3d hemos encontrado una gran herramienta
que nos ha dado un apoyo impresionante
porque para empezar el diseño puede
jugar con todo esto y los niños que
tienen una imaginación muy alta que
colocan una vara muy alta para nuestro
trabajo la impresión 3d nos ha dado
muchas posibilidades para realizar lo
que ellos quieran
muchas veces
tener un pensamiento creativo al ver las
cosas desde otra perspectiva
no suele dar otras posibilidades para
hacer las cosas
el estar trabajando
en ámbitos fuera del que al que le
corresponde a uno también le da un un
aprendizaje muy alto con respecto a las
otras personas a los otros profesionales
este proyecto lo inauguró un ingeniero
mecatrónico y hola ahora él a veces
habla como un artista y yo a veces medio
más cruel cuadriculado más como un
matemático la gente no pensaría que de
pronto yo soy como los denominados
chirris que a veces nombran por ahí
el pensamiento creativo no es lo que
muchas veces las personas asocian
a saber dibujar a saber pintar a saber
esculpir no es ese tipo de cosas eso
sólo son herramientas son técnicas en el
manejo de un trabajo
es algo puramente técnico
el pensamiento creativo sobre todo
tener ideas resolver problemáticas de
una forma práctica rápida interesante
innovadora
de una manera impactante
si ustedes lo pueden hacer y lo pueden
reunir considérese artistas
y de pronto tal vez el mensaje que yo
les puedo dar ahorita
esta es una forma en la cual digamos yo
planteo
o yo planteé una forma de hacer la
diferencia con una realidad que está
pasando
la posibilidad de pararse desde otro
ángulo
es lo que nos puede dar una perspectiva
diferente y bueno esta es mi manera de
hacerlo esta es la forma como yo lo hago
cuál puede ser la herramienta de ustedes
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]